my favorite disease is arthritis i love
arthritis
the reason why i love arthritis is it's
easy to fix and when you can fix
something as horrible and as
debilitating as painful as expensive and
as miserable as arthritis you get kind
of excited about this concept of
preventing and curing diseases with
nutrition
and so i tell people about this
arthritis thing all the time so let's
have a quick look at arthritis number
one 75 to 80 of all americans over the
age of 50 get arthritis to one degree or
one type or another and according to the
cdc the center for disease control 35 to
50 million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next seven to ten years
and there's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or fix it
aspirin certainly doesn't fix arthritis
causes gastric bleeding and death
tylenol doesn't fix arthritis causes
fifty thousand cases of kidney failure
each year five thousand which are so
severe you need a kidney transplant then
there's ibuprofen advil and a leave
these things don't fix arthritis and
they cause liver disease in two to five
percent of the users including liver
cirrhosis even if you don't drink and
then there's methotrexate and gold shots
these things don't fix arthritis they
subdue your bone marrow so you can't
make normal platelets and white blood
cells and then you have the granddaddies
of all the medical treatments for
arthritis prednisone and cortisone they
don't fix arthritis they subdue your
immune system which leaves you open to
diseases far far more horrible than
arthritis and prednisone and cortisone
accelerate the loss of minerals from
your bones something you don't want when
you have osteoporosis and arthritis now
when these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain inflammation the
only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and i i never
like to send my patients in for joint
replacement surgery because they never
work out well in fact many times you're
worse off after the surgery than you
were before the surgery the advantage my
patients have always had is that i'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician and
so i always used to tell my patients
look we have all these nutritional
formulas designed to prevent and cure
diseases and animals including arthritis
and so i tried adapting nutritional
arthritis formulas designed to prevent
and cure arthritis and pigeons and
turkeys dogs cats sheeps pigs horses
cows lions tigers and bears to human use
it was no surprise to me it works just
as well in humans as a dozen animals
because it was designed to prevent and
cure arthritis in pigs and i've
literally seen tens of thousands of
people who've had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90. i've seen people 97 years old
regrow cartilage and bone even if they
had bone to bone arthritis if there's
blood supply to that joint and that bone
they will regrow
bone and cartilage well of course
harvard medical school goes berserk when
you say stuff like that while like you
can't say those things the only thing
left for people when they get bone to
bone arthritis is joint replacement
surgery and i'd agree with them if the
only raw materials you're using is
tylenol and aspirin and prednisone and
cortisone we've learned over 50 years
that you can't regrow cartilage and bone
using those things one of the basic
things of course at the harvard medical
school jumped onto and they said this is
so ridiculous that this couldn't work
and so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis
over 15 to 20 years they took them off
all their medication wasn't working for
them anyway lined them up for joint
replacement surgery they said look for
90 days before we do the surgery they
gave them a heaping tablespoon full of
ground up chicken cartilage their orange
juice every morning for 90 days they
were sort of chuckling in their beer
saying nothing's gonna happen well
here's what happened in 10 days these
people these 29 people had complete
relief of pain inflammation something
they hadn't had in 15 to 20 years
in 30 days they could now open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
without pain to the fingers wrist elbows
and shoulders
in 90 days 28 of the 29 were clinically
cured now this is from harvard medical
school in the boston va that meant that
they had complete return to the range of
motion all the pain inflammation was
gone in their fingers and toes and hips
and knees and her neck and certainly
many of them still had knots on their
fingers because it was only 90 days and
you think they'd call me up these
professors you know of medicine from
harvard medical school and from the
boston va and say look wallet we have to
apologize to you we've been bad mouthing
you for 20 years and why don't you come
up to boston let's talk about the whole
thing here's what they said quote after
three months it was clear that the drug
was beneficial unquote chicken cartilage
had become a drug in 90 days
now why would that happen well because
you can't patent chicken cartilage and
they convinced at the u.s patent office
that they were using a drug to do this
study and they actually got a use patent
on chicken cartilage
and you too for 3 500 bucks a month can
get harvard medical school's chicken
cartilage and capsule for arthritis of
course cartilage has chondroitin sulfate
in it glucosamine sulfate collagen these
are all the basic raw materials to
rebuild cartilage and bone
you